welcome to Hannity busy news night we're
glad you're with us because we are
tracking multiple major breaking stories
as we begin and tonight the deep state
is in even more deep trouble no pun
intended
US Attorney John Durham has been
appointed to investigate the origins of
the Russia probe this is huge news this
is the boomerang we've been telling you
about a massive step forward now Durham
is a nonpartisan career US attorney he
specializes in uncovering corruption at
the highest levels of our federal
government now back in the early 2000s
Durham was appointed to investigate the
FBI's Boston Police field office and
resulting in a conviction of an FBI
special agent as well as another
law-enforcement official connected to
the notorious gangster Whitey Bulger
in 2009 Durham was appointed to
investigate abuses in the CIA over his
decades-long career
well Durham has successfully prosecuted
dozens of government officials gang
members drug traffickers alike and he
has been praised by members on both
sides of the aisle for his steady and
cautious pursuit of truth and of justice
and tonight he is squarely focused on
why our country's most sensitive
intelligence tools were turned against
its own citizens at the height of a
presidential election now Fox News is
reporting that Durham is collaborating
with the Inspector General Michael
Horowitz in his ongoing investigation
into FISA abuse and FISA abuse fraud and
get this storms investigation is not new
it has now been underway for weeks and
possibly even months and needless to say
the bad actors in a deep state they are
getting very nervous tonight and they're
now turning on each other little
circular firing squad forming Lisa Paige
Peter struck while they're blaming
Loretta Lynch for the rigging of the
investigation into Hillary Clinton and
her server and obstruction of justice
and Bruce Orwell he's blaming the DOJ
and FBI officials for ignoring his
warning about Christopher steel and the
dossier well that was in August of 2016
James Comey is trashing struck and page
on national TV and he's also in a fight
with Rod Rosenstein they're attacking
each other's character and also Andrew
McCabe is attacking anyone pretty much
with the pulse
well it's crisis mode for the deep state
and it's every man every woman for
themselves even commis former general
counsel at the FBI James Baker he's
trying to get ahead of this story by
warning that Horowitz is going to
uncover some major mistakes in the FISA
process you think take a look the
inspector general is looking at
everything that we did and if you know
the IG usually finds mistakes that we
made and so I expect him to find
mistakes this time but I can say that
you know at least from the intent of the
people that I was dealing with there was
no intention to do anything wrong or
illegal let's say mistakes you mean like
using untrue something that is
unverifiable Russian misinformation
propaganda outright lies pay for by
Hillary Clinton to literally inform the
American people because it was leaked to
The Washington Post David corn and
Michael Isikoff as the very basis for a
warrant to spy not only on an American
citizen but an American citizen working
for the Trump campaign and the entire
opposition party that none of these guys
we know wanted to win that election well
interesting well like when James Comey
swore that information provided to the
FISA Court he signed that first FISA
application he was signing that that was
true and correct and verified and
corroborated and by the way the
application has the word verified on it
now mr. Baker that would not be a
mistake that would be willful
premeditated a criminal act committed
for the sole purpose of deceiving and
committing a fraud on the FISA Court and
stripping Americans of their
constitutional inalienable rights while
trying to also simultaneously rig a
presidential election in the United
States and not only did call me make no
attempt to verify or corroborate
Steele's so-called intelligence well
there is now again
more growing evidence tonight the Comey
knew full well that steel was completely
unreliable a brand new report breaking
from investigative reporter from the
hill John Solomon showing that the State
Department official Kathleen Cadillac
did in fact inform a high-ranking
official at the FBI about her meeting
with Steele many days many 10 days
before the FISA warrant against Carter
Paige the first one was submitted in
October of 2016
here on this developing story
investigative reporter from the hill we
of our friend John Solomon is with us
all right this is getting more
interesting by the day and there is no
doubt that they will warrant especially
Bruce or warned everybody that was in
his closed-door testimony but in this
particular case this woman miss Cadillac
she in fact warned them directly yeah
it's important for the first time we
know who in the chain of command
actually got tipped off by the State
Department that Steele had made this
remarkable appearance on October 11 2016
the person she identified as a guy named
Stephen Leacock at the time he was the
section chief for Eurasia inside the FBI
counterintelligence investigation so the
division that was doing the Russia
investigation my sources tell me he
immediately forwarded cadillacs
information to the team running the
Russia case which would have been beat
strokes team why is this important we
know from the October 11th meeting notes
now that the State Department detected
from Steele inaccurate information about
his allegations about Russia collusion
that he had an election deadline a
political motive an election day
deadline to get this at dirt on Trump
out to the public and that he had been
leaking to the media specifically the
Washington Post in New York Times the
FBI should have gone and checked that
out that's what former people who L who
held cavil mr. Laycock job today the
prior predecessors say that's what we do
at the FBI when we get a tip-off that
our our informant is rogue talking you
go back and you check it you don't just
proceed with your FISA and ignore what
went on so a very important development
tonight and a new witness identified for
those in Congress in the inspector
general's investigations all right what
do you know about what's going on with
the inspect
general reported mr. Durham who's been
appointed and our reporting tonight
shows that he has been working for at
least a number weeks if not maybe months
yeah I think that most significantly
this gives the inspector general
investigation the ability to get grand
jury subpoenas through a sitting US
Attorney so it creates a new
investigative tool that Inspector
General's don't normally have they're
usually administrative in their approach
and remember some of the people that are
key witnesses no longer fall under the
Justice Department's purview they're
former employees because they were
either fired or resigned so the US
attorney of great reputation of
investigating fairly and honestly but
toughly prior controversies inside the
FBI he's now involved in that tool the
grand jury subpoena is another piece
that can be played here to get to the
bottom of the truth
all right investigative reporter with
the hill John Solomon thanks for joining
us tonight and truth and justice as
we've been telling you it's now
happening it's cascading down no one in
the deep state is safe from justice
which is why they're all turning on each
other
operation boomerang no longer operation
crossfire hurricane is in full effect
the Russian hoax is now in the rearview
mirror Muller is over the entire witch
hunt anything you hear here going
forward well that is only noise the
president didn't collude he didn't
obstruct and the left's fake phony
narrative about the Trump campaign their
conspiracies about Russia is not even on
life support at this time it is dead
it's buried and it's not coming back
but the anti-trump mob especially in the
media they just can't seem to let it go
that includes by the way James clapper
who was literally begging CNN to get
back on message get back to the
conspiracy theory that's been disproven
four times sure great TV coverage we're
kind of losing sight of what was the
cause of all this the predicate for all
this was the Russians and the Russian
engagement now we know with parently
dozens of cases were Russian operatives
some of whom were known to be have
intelligence connections we're trying to
engage with the Trump campaign that's
what the concern was it was a predicate
for for any of these invested
this investigation I wish people pay
more attention to volume one of the
molar report the exhaust of detail but
what the Russians did and we're losing
sight of that actually while James many
Republicans like congressman Devin Nunez
he'll be joining us tonight
they've been warning about the Russia
threat for years 2014 most recently this
all happened under your watch and
Biden's and Obama's watch but it was
then President Obama he was us laughing
it off tell Vladimir I'll have more
flexibility after the election if you
look at the volume one of the Muller
report you will see it was the Trump
campaign that rebuffed Russian
operations every step of the way
and while it was the Clinton campaign
who actually paid for Russian
disinformation in the form of a dirty
dossier full of Russian lives New York
Times suggesting maybe Russian
disinformation from the get-go that
dirty Russian dossier that you James
clapper allegedly leaked to your current
employer fake news CNN yeah that one but
James tick-tock because John ubers
investigation into leaking is around the
corner
of course that's no concern of the house
Intel chairman that would be Adam the
Cowardly Schiff who doesn't seem to care
about government leaking or abuse of
power because Schiff is on an
all-consuming mission to smear slander
besmirch attacked the President of the
United States which is exactly why he is
desperately trying to get Robert Muller
to appear before Congress maybe he
hasn't realized it's over yet maybe
somebody needs to tell him take a look
we're in conversation with a special
counsels office and it's not that
they've confirmed a date but this is
gonna happen it has to I think the
Republicans and I think the Attorney
General even understand that that's why
Barr has said repeatedly he's not gonna
stand in the way of Muller testimony I
think that's because he knows he can't
that's just a bridge too far even for
them he said he had evidence to and
everything the only one that we have on
tape colluding with Russians is him
remember he was talking to a Russian
hoaxster who said that he had while
damning information on Donald Trump and
he was asked well what
the nature of the information and naked
tadam thank you Tom the fladam ears see
it
yes but the course but of course
bullzooka surrounding an actual hoax and
conspiracy theory four separate
investigations cleared president Trump
the FBI's nine-month investigation under
Comey
came up with nothing the special
council's 20 month investigation nothing
the house Intel committee's
investigation nothing the bipartisan
Senate investigation nothing but then
you got sleepy creepy Uncle Joe Biden
who's desperate to try and win and
delineate himself from the radical
leftist in his own party well some
saying even the front-runner at this
moment he's not going to let facts get
in the way during a question-and-answer
session on the campaign trail sleepy
creepy Uncle Joe put on his tinfoil hat
conspiracy theory game and pushed his
favorite Trump Russian conspiracy theory
shocking just lie to the American people
and hope it works
he's an illegitimate president in my
mind he's illegitimate and my biggest
fear is that he's gonna do it again with
the help of Vlad his best pal and we're
gonna be stuck for six more years of
this guy and that is terrifying
it's terrified you be my vice president
some folks look I absolutely agree and
one of the things we have to do here we
got to get this part straight in my view
all right like most Democrats running
for office Biden is willing to say
anything to score a cheap political
point whether they're smearing a nominee
to the US Supreme Court or attacking
even a 16 year old high school kid for
daring to wear a make America great
again hat or pushing a Russia hoax over
nearly three years now
the left's quest for power knows no
bounds Biden Obama had their shot what
did they give us thirteen million more
Americans on food stamps eight million
more in poverty the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s the
worst recovery since the 40s lowest hold
roller ship rate in 51 years not one
year the only presidency never to give
us three percent GDP growth and they
took on more debt
than all 43 presidents before them
combined Joe run on that record and by
the way
sleepy creepy Russia happened on your
watch what did you know and when did you
know it on this program we will always
demand the presumption of innocence
equal justice due process the pursuit of
truth but buckle up it's going to be a
huge year full of massive developments
and lots of lies